[Music]
laura is with us in alaska hi laura
welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave and rachel thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um uh my question today is uh how to
best support my husband through a career
change um
he was a framer in college uh mostly
working for his father's residential
contractor business
but he's been in banking for the past
seven years and um he's he's trying to
change his careers to go
back to being um like a project manager
or a residential contractor
and uh so far in the last like three
four months
we've put about two thousand dollars
into classes and exams and his next exam
um tries uh is next week um he doesn't
want a huge pay cut right now he's
making between
eighty and a hundred thousand a year
with uh bonuses um so he doesn't want
like to start over with his career
now that he's been doing this a while um
and and it's just kind of a
it's just kind of led to a lot of
it's just a lot of angst i guess but um
i guess my question is like how to best
support him through that uh through all
of this big change that's happening
because he will his income go down with
the new job
um so
like it's
starting a whole new business as a
residential contractor first needs a
license and many
clients and uh it's hard to get a loan
without experience like he's looked into
getting a loan for like
a contract loan um
for for building a house for someone but
so he wants to um get credit cards and
get more credit and be able to build a
house he
sold his fancy truck and and bought a a
cheaper truck and so we have forty
thousand saved for a plot of land but
i guess it's just kind of a it's kind of
an unclear direction of how to start a
business and
and and he knows how to do all that it's
just um
it's going to be hard because he like to
quit his job that makes 80 000 to start
a business that potentially might not
make anything for a year or two and um
it's just
i guess it's just kind of an unclear
path and we'll both kind of start well
and part of the problem is it is a clear
path uh it's just a bad one and that's
part of what's bothering him and you
because what you're describing to me is
ultra high risk
you're setting yourself up for
bankruptcy
so no you don't need to do what you're
doing i would recommend not doing his
path
um
hold on hold on hold on
i do want him to go be a residential
contractor
and i do want him to make this change
i do not want him building a house for
someone else with him with money he
borrowed
lots of contractors
do cost plus
or even
a profit margin agreement whichever it
is and they're very similar
and so if i got ready to build a house i
could put up the money
and hire a contractor
and they use my money to build my house
and he makes a profit
that is a normal arrangement in custom
home building
you don't need to go into debt to build
a house for somebody else they should
have the money
and if they don't have the money they
can go get a construction loan and if
your husband has a contractor's license
in the state of arkansas the bank will
loan them the money against a set of
plans an appraisal and then and you're
able to draw on the construction loan as
as percentages of completion on the pro
on the house are done in no case is your
husband or you on the debt
the individual building that that's
going to end up owning the house goes
and gets the construction loan and then
the draw comes out and when the draw
comes out it's to pay the lumber bill
and to pay the contractor a percentage
of his profit because we reached the 50
mark or the 25 mark or whatever
and that's it's laid out in a normal
construction draw
program it's typically done for instance
after the foundation is in there's one
draw after the framing package is up is
another draw uh those are typical very
i've been around this business my whole
life and been in it my whole life so
but there's no reason for you to have to
go borrow money to buy a plot of land to
build something on that is not a good
way to do this and in the meantime i
would start doing a bunch of renovations
and build decks and build other things
on the side as a side hustle and get my
volume up and get my customer base up
before i quit
because in order to build a custom home
he's going to have to be full-time
yes definitely i've i've sent him jobs
like carpenter jobs and and other things
but he he really doesn't want to take a
pay cut like in between like i want him
to do that as a side hustle
evening yeah no pay cut
put some guys up put some guys on the
job building the deck go by and see them
before work and after work and check
them on the weekends
and sub it's about the work
with his with his contractor's license
do some renovations same way but he does
not have to be on the job all day long
on these small projects
and there's no pay cut involved because
he's still got his banker job
until he gets his income up and gets
enough
and he gets two or three custom houses
lined up and okay we're getting ready to
break ground this month on one next
month on another next month on another
and you've got those under contract
meaning the the people building the
house have signed a contract with you to
be their contractor now you've got
business that you can quit a based on
okay but you don't have to go into debt
to do this and you don't have to quit
cold turkey to go do this
okay
cool i i will i will let him know okay
and i i can be very supportive of all
that because i think he could actually
make about double what he's making now
with this move i think he's going to
make more and do stuff he loves
and he kind of cut his teeth on the
business he grew up in the business but
guys who go out and just start spec
building as we're heading into a
recession the ones that get their butts
kicked
yeah
yeah and and you and you feel that angst
laura like even when you were asking the
question i could hear your voice
you weren't sure what to be nervous
about but you just knew it wasn't right
yeah it's it
yeah yeah i love him i want him to win i
don't want to i don't want to kill his
dream but i'm feeling like a nightmare
and does is he would he receive this
like if you kind of walked through this
call
um of just different ideas versus i'm
gonna quit tomorrow and go into debt to
build a house and all that like
what is his what's his level of um
comfortable is he comfortable in his
plan
um
i don't i don't fully think
he is he um
it's it sounds bad but dave ramsey's
been a bit of a curse word in our in our
you know 10-month marriage and like i
got i i got myself out of debt he paid
for the wedding with cash
and uh but we both you know we're not on
a strict budget but we have shared bank
account it's just kind of um it's just
been i don't know a little tense with
with all of this change and underneath
all of it is just kind of that he's just
really unhappy with his current career
choice and it's just brought a lot of
frustration i'm completely in agreement
with him i would much rather build
houses and be a banker
oh man it just sounds like a whole lot
more fun to me
so i'm totally i'm totally supportive of
his dream but here's the thing you can
always do a dream
with improper steps and turn it into a
nightmare and that's what i don't want
for him or for you
and laura too i would i would kind of
push into this because you guys have
been married 10 months
it kind of feels like a little bit of
shaky foundation of like we're not we're
on the same page but we're not here and
it's this and i'm kind of tiptoeing
around different stuff i mean you guys
kind of just need to have a over dinner
this weekend just say hey
i just need to say out loud the things
that i'm thinking and feeling and i want
you to hear them and it takes courage to
do that but for him to hear that and you
guys start these kind of conversations
because tiptoeing around the issues
is get is starting out a terrible habit
for marriage
are you all like 26
uh we're we're
30 and 31. okay yeah because here
here's what
i'm old so when someone says to me how
can i be supportive of my husband and
then they lay out all of the things that
he's doing that don't feel right that's
code for i think this is a really stupid
idea how can i really tell him that and
still love him
and still and still want him to go
off you know i mean it's it's code for
you know you don't really want to be
supportive of him doing cocaine you know
you don't
how can i be supportive of my husband
while he does a little cocaine no you
can't you can't do that that's you're
not supportive of that
and it's sweet but it's just wrong you
know no i my wife does not support me
and things that she thinks is crazy but
you can be respectful in the
conversation absolutely being honest
where you are lord to him i think is one
of the biggest gifts you can give him
no obligation to support things that
violate your
beliefs and your common sense
don't support those because you're going
down with the ship you're on the ship
you know both of you are on it together